and
in an entirely natural world without our
need supernatural mysteries you can
explain the mind the human mind
consciousness it's been my project for
50 years and what I've come to realize
this that's the only way to do it right
is you have to take evolution a lot more
seriously and really look hard at the
question of how evolution could have
gotten these wonderful projects up and
running that have now led to people like
you and me and all the great artistic
geniuses and scientific geniuses the the
real intelligent designers that now
inhabit the planet instead of the
imaginary intelligent designer who never
existed from millennia people had it in
mind that all the wonderful things I saw
in the world all the beautiful design of
the animals and plants and living things
must be due to a fabulously intelligent
designer a creator and so it was until
Darwin came along and turned that upside
down and realized that in principle
there could be a process with no
intelligence no comprehension no
foresight no purpose that would just
inexorably grind out algorithmically
better and better and better designs of
all sorts and create the living world
where there had been just lifeless
matter before and this was a shocking
idea to many people even to Darwin in
some regards it was shocking but he was
right he had the essentials right and
now 150 years later there's just no
question about it he was right and we're
filling in the details at a breathtaking
pace so that was the first great
inversion a strange inversion of Reason
and it's much abetted in recent years by
what I call Alan Turing strange
inversion of reasoning when touring came
along computers were people that was a
job what do you do for a living I'm a
computer and these are human beings
typically they were math majors and they
were hired to compute various functions
tables logarithms celestial navigation
tables and so forth what toring realizes
you didn't have to be intelligent you
didn't have to comprehend you could make
a device which did all the things that
the human computers are doing with all
the intelligence and all the
understanding laundered out of it except
for the most minimal sort of mechanical
quasi understanding you all had to do is
to be able to tell a zero from a 1 or a
hole in a punch tape from no hole in the
punch tape a very simple discriminator
put it together with the right logic in
you have a universal Turing machine
which can compute anything computable
and that was the birth of the computer
and the two strange inversions fit
together beautifully what they show and
this is still strange to people is what
I call competence without comprehension
we tend to think that the reason we send
our children to university is so that
they can acquire comprehension which we
view as the source of competence it's
out of that well of comprehension that
they acquire the competences they do and
we look down our noses at rote learning
and drill and practice because that's
that's just competence we want
comprehension and what touring and
Darwin in very similar ways showed us
now that's just backwards comprehension
is an effect of multiple competences not
itself a source an independent source of
competence so that's the second strain
of conversion if we want to look at
human minds we have to add another
source of
Ellucian arey power and that's cultural
evolution we don't get all our
intelligence from our genes in fact
relatively little all things considered
and here's where Touring's ideas really
come in handy because if you take
Richard Dawkins idea of the mean as a
unit of cultural evolution and you take
Touring's idea about a programmable
computer and you put them together you
get the idea of a meme as a thing made
of information it's like an app which
you download to your neck top and it's a
brain filled with apps is the mind is a
human mind and if you don't download all
the apps you're not going to be able to
think very well and that's why no
creature on the planet however
intelligent they are in some regard they
can't hold a candle to us because they
can't download the apps of culture
because they don't have basically they
don't have a language and its language
which is itself composed of memes words
or means it's language that is the
backbone of cultural evolution and what
it permits is for cultural evolution
become ever less Darwinian ever more
intelligent and now we're living in the
age of intelligent design we have
scientists and engineers and artists and
musicians and composers all these
wonderful designers and wonderful things
poems bridges airplanes theories and
they are intelligent designers but if
you want to know how they manage to have
that intelligence you have to go back
and look at their brains as ultimately
like touring touring machines they're
composed of actually trillions of moving
parts that are all just as stupid as
posts they don't understand a thing they
don't have to
anything you put them together in the
right way and you get comprehension and
eventually consciousness
[Music]